(cheerful music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits," the podcast,
where two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the Round
Table of Dim Lighting
we are talking about sibling
dynamics and personality tropes
specifically--
- Hm mm.
- the whole birth order thing.
We actually put a prompt out to you
saying exactly that, "Let's
talk sibling dynamics
"and personality tropes on Ear Biscuits."
Tell us how being the oldest, youngest,
middle or only child
influenced who you are.
Feel free to dish dirt on
your parents and siblings too.
- Yeah!
So we're gonna group this
conversation by the type
of sibling that they said
they were, and you know,
we'll we'll get in where we fit in.
But I think we should
probably just go ahead
and establish what we are.
- Yeah, well, between the two of us
we'd represent two different things.
And between our families, we represent
all the categories.
- Everything!
- I'm a younger child--
- You're one of--
- youngest sibling of two.
- you have one other
- Older brother.
- one older brother.
- Cole!
- His name is Coal.
- Not spelled like the rock.
It's not a rock.
- It was originally,
but then he changed it
out of embarrassment.
Just kidding.
(Link chuckling)
It's a family name, C-O-L-E.
- Age difference is?
- The age difference is about three years.
But school, was...
- He was a senior in high school
when you were a freshmen.
- Would you call that three years?
- I will call that three years.
- Three years.
Yeah--
- Supposed to be
in high school together.
- And so about two and a half years in age
and about three years in school.
- Yeah.
- I'm an only child.
(Rhett guffaws)
Yeah--
- Surprise, surprise.
- The one
(Link chuckles)
and the only, the special one, you know...
If it ain't broke, don't have more kids.
I'm like just pristine
and a perfect little baby.
- Just like an only child would say.
- Yeah, I know, of course
I'm totally joking.
I've got maybe, maybe
there's some bitterness
that I'm gonna uncover once we get to
discussing my experience.
I did have half-siblings for a while.
Well I had a half, not a half sister,
I had a stepsister in the
house for like grade school
and she was in high school.
And then by the time I
was in third grade-ish
mom got a divorce and
it was just me and mom.
She was not, she had, I mean,
she might've had prospects
to make more babies.
We haven't discussed this.
- Prospects?
- But, I mean...
- I remember a few.
- She had some boyfriends.
- I remember a few boyfriends.
(Links chuckles)
- The brown, you remember
the brownie points boyfriend?
- Brownie points boyfriend.
- We always talk about
Brownie Points-guy.
- He's stuck out the most.
- She was dating him.
- Walt?
- Yeah, his name was Walt!
(Rhett crowing)
- I don't know how
I remember that!
- By that time I was,
I must've been 16 because
I would come home--
- You were younger than that
when they started dating.
- I do remember being 16 and driving home
and mom wasn't home because her car wasn't
under the car port, but his car was there,
and he was sitting--
- Sitting on the stoop.
- on the the stoop.
I'm pretty sure he was drinking a beer.
- He had a six pack.
- Yeah.
(Rhett guffaws)
Yeah, I remember this story.
I wasn't there.
I just remember my mom
telling me, she was like,
"Now Link got home and Walt
was sitting on the stoop,
"drinking beer, he had a whole six pack."
That's, I just remember--
- I mean, that's just
the start of it.
- And I was like, whoa!
- A nice Netflix and chill
is what he's thinking.
- In our world, it was
like, he may be dangerous.
(Rhett laughing)
You know what I'm saying?
That's how I thought about it.
- And I was, like, it was weird for me.
It wasn't like, my mom wanted to make sure
that I was okay with her dating somebody.
Walt was a fine guy.
You know, there was
nothing wrong with the guy.
He was, I seem to remember
him a bit of a tool.
Like, I mean, yes, there was a time when
he dropped us off at the
party and on the way there
my mom was in the car
too, but it was me and you
being dropped off at
probably what was like
an eighth grade or ninth
ninth grade make-out party--
- Yeah, the best.
- and he started talking
about brownie points--
- Hm mm.
- And I--
- Still didn't really understand--
- Don't know what--
- but I'm pretty sure
I got some that night.
You got some brownie points?
- I racked up
on brownie points.
- She also dated, this is
just sort of me dishing
who my mom dated--
- This has nothing to do--
- Before she got,
- With what we're gonna be talking about.
- Happily remarried.
- Listen, can you just
table that conversation?
- Let's table that...
- Because you've got three children--
- But I'm basically an only child
and then I got three children.
- So you got older, middle and younger
and I've got two boys.
- That's why we had three-
- Older and younger---
- Just to see what it was like.
- I knew about the middle child tropes.
And so we didn't have a
middle child on purpose.
- No, I think you forgot
to have a middle child.
- And our kids are...
- That's what happens
with the middle children.
- Five years...
- Forgotten.
- So five years apart.
Your kids are like two
years apart each, right?
- Lando's a little bit more.
Lando's 11, Lilly's 18 Lincoln, 16.
- Whoa, so like five.
So you got like two and then five?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Anyway, so before we get into
some of the responses,
we did a little boopity-boop research.
I do wanna just,
(Link vocalizing)
just up top here, a lot of the responses
that we're going to give
are going to fall into,
what you may already have
in your mind as a trope,
or as what you think
is established science
about some of these
stereotypes of middle child,
you know, the different sibling order,
but just to kinda get
all that out of the way
without getting into it...
If you take all the studies
and try to condense them
down to just some sort of
predictable guidelines,
or understanding of sibling order--
- You guessed it, it's indeterminate.
- It's inconclusive.
- Lots of conflicting data.
- And I'm not saying that it doesn't exist
and I'm not saying that sibling
order doesn't have an impact
on who you are, but most of
the studies seem to indicate
that once you become
an adult, these things,
other things about your
personality kind of went out
and it isn't what order you were born in
that determines who you're gonna be
for the rest of your life.
I don't know if that's
comforting, or upsetting to you,
based on how you've
thought about your life.
- Of course, once you get
into the specific dynamics
of the specific people
that you grew up with,
that has a tremendous impact
on who you are as a person,
but just to boil it
down to birth order is,
you know, it oversimplifies things
and science is not gonna--
- And I think--
- Peg it down.
- I actually, I'm resistant
to this even though
this is what the science shows
or doesn't show--
- Yeah, I know.
- I'm resistant to it
because I've always thought
about my children and, well
really not as much my kids.
I think my kids kinda go
against this in some ways,
but me and my brother, I think
hit some of those tropes.
And I've always thought
that me compared to you
hit some of the tropes
of grew up with kids,
grew up with siblings,
grew up as an only child.
- Yeah.
- I've always attributed
some of the things about you
and some of the things about
me and our differences to that.
And maybe I just been wrong all along?
- Let's start with oldest and
work our way down that way.
You know, we're saving the best for last.
And I'm talking about me, the only child.
- Exactly.
(Link chuckles)
- Starting with Jada.
That's Jada Leigh Frost.
"Oh, isn't being the oldest horrible."
- Hm?
- "The trial kid."
They test it all out on us then
the younger ones have it easier.
This might be the most universal trope.
- I think the next one we're gonna read,
vies for that position.
But yeah, I mean, certainly
when Lily came along,
you know, you got this first child,
you wanna do everything right.
And especially...
You know there's people
here having babies, like--
- Here on earth?
- Kevin @mythical--
- Oh, here @mythical.
- Kevin's wife just had a baby.
- Yeah.
- They're doing great.
And they're at such a, you
know, I was just reflecting,
they're at such a different
point in their lives
than we were when we started having.
- Full of hope.
- But they're older, you know?
Kevin's older, he's wiser.
He can, you know, he's...
I anticipate he's not gonna
wig out in the way that I did
when I would like.
I still felt kinda like a newlywed.
- Well, because--
- Couple of years
of marriage--
- Just few years before--
- 23 years old.
- You were a teenager!.
- Yeah!
- It was a few years
removed from teenage hood.
- So definitely with us as
young, young parents of a first
and eventually oldest child,
is that you wanna get everything right.
There was all these rules
and systems in place
in the Neal-house for Lily.
And I think that we were
trying a lot out on her
that then, yeah, it absolutely,
everything that we experienced with Lily,
impacted what we pivoted to
with Lincoln, or with Lando.
I mean, you know, it's...
I'm trying to think of an example
that doesn't have to do
with punishing the kids,
but you go from...
I mean, is it...
I brought up spanking on
Good Mythical Morning.
I guess that's really controversial.
- I guess,
(Rhett chuckles)
- But--
- And it is.
Today it is, yes.
- And Lando was never spanked.
Lily was not spanked a lot,
but it was something that was taught
and that was part of a system.
And, you know, it was...
There were certain ways
that you could go about it
that were, you know, not abusive,
I think was what was
going on in our minds.
I'm not saying that spanking
across the board is abusive.
I'm still not gonna say that
because my experience with her
was that it was...
I felt like we were doing the right thing.
We changed our minds
over the next two kids.
Well, by the time we got to Lando, really,
we changed our minds.
But Lily didn't need a
lot of spanking anyway.
So, it wasn't like we
really wrestled with it.
We just kinda moved on and it wasn't.
We moved to timeouts pretty quickly
even with Lily.
- I will say that--
- But with timeout,
timeouts didn't work with Lincoln
and then with Lando they did.
- Culturally
where we, not just in North Carolina,
but again, the culture
that we were a part of
in North Carolina, it was,
you know, "Spare the rod
spoil the child" right.
And so basically everyone
was, again, we're talking
spanking on the bottom.
We're limiting it to that.
But then there was this
sort of--
- An emotion, like not--
- Not out anger.
- Not out of anger.
- Right.
- Basically I honestly, the
way that I was brought up,
my brother and I were both spanked.
It was...
Again, my wife is the one
who's done the research
and the reading on all this stuff.
Our wives are the one--
- Right.
- That do all of the
reading about parenting
and most of the parenting,
let's just be honest.
- Yeah.
- But, and Jesse has
strong feelings about this.
Basically saying that she feels
she's completely sort of
flipped her perspective
on the role of spanking.
Now I...
But just to say that I think that
there's definitely a spectrum
of how it can be administered, right?
We're not here to defend
it and we're not here.
Why don't you--
- I'm sorry
I got you into this.
- You brought it up again
and it's such a controversial thing
that I just don't even want to,
- But it's good illustration
- Talk about it.
- of like, if you got your
first child and she gets spanked
and then your third
child never gets spanked.
I mean, it is a good example
of like how things change
and you learn and
- Well, and we were--
- I'm sorry,
but if you're the first
child, in one way or another
in every way, you inform what
happens with every other child
moving forward.
- I mean,
I guess what I can say is--
- That seems like it sucks,
to me.
- If the same thing was
true in our household
and Locke was the one who was, you know.
We were undergoing, sort of,
our own personal evolution.
Our worldview was being
turned completely upside down
as our kids grew up, which
is a whole different,
a whole different thing.
- That's true.
- And studies will be done
about kids in this generation
(Rhett chuckles)
because there are so many people
whose worldviews are changing right now.
But setting that aside,
if you just isolate that,
the way that we punished
Locke, both the frequency,
the intensity
was definitely, we were
more lenient with Shepard,
but it wasn't just because
he was a younger child,
it was because we were changing the way
that we were thinking about parenting.
And I can say that thus far--
- And discipline specifically.
- There doesn't seem to
be a notable difference
between the two of them
in that particular.
It's more determined by their disposition
and their personality
and less the way that we
are interacting with them.
That's another thing that
I think has shifted for me
over time.
And I do think that, the
science shows this is that,
one of the ideas from the
culture that we came from
is that the parents have...
The weight of responsibility,
like your kids,
I mean, literally, just
Bible verses that talk about
if you train a child up in
the way that they should go,
they will not depart from it
when they become an adult.
And so, there's actually a lot of shame
in a lot of religious circles,
when your kid departs from
that, or your kid ends up being
a hellion when they grow up,
that means that you did something wrong.
I'm kinda coming to the conclusion that,
yes, parenting is very important,
but a lot of it is based on
what you model, not what you say
and also a lot based on their disposition.
So, that's a little bit of an aside.
- And we were very focused
on, even at the beginning,
based on the books that we were reading.
I remember there was a book called,
"Shepherding a Child's Heart,"
which I thought was very helpful.
I don't remember the specifics of it now,
so I'm not recommending it now.
It was so long ago,
you know, 17, 16 years ago.
But being focused on
not just getting a kid
to robotically respond and do
what we want the kid to do,
but understand our children's
hearts and who they are
and how to shepherd their
heart into blossoming
as a loving individual
and, you,
- Yeah.
- a well-developed...
And probably, yeah, at certain
times, it boils down to just
well-mannered
(Link chuckles)
kid.
So--
- But this wasn't.
I gotta say--
- I can't think of another trial,
some other things that I changed.
- This wasn't true for
me as a child though.
It's almost like...
I mean, my dad was so consistent.
He was so consistent.
And my mom.
Both of them
were so consistent--
- Hm mm.
- In what they thought
and how they parented
from the beginning until we left.
And I don't,
I never perceived a noticeable change
between the way that I was treated
and the way that my brother was treated.
Now--
- Hmm?
So you don't think Cole
would say he was the trial
and then they adjusted it for you?
- That may have been happening,
but I never sensed it.
- Right.
- Looking back at it.
I don't have any tangible
examples of that,
but for my kids, it's more of a 100% yes.
The leniency that we operate with towards
Shepard is definitely higher
than what we did with Locke
and it's based less on, I mean,
I think it's a combination
of just like, you don't
have so much attention
now there's two of them.
I can only devote so
much attention to them.
But also it's just,
this didn't seem to work that well.
He didn't listen to all.
He didn't listen.
(Rhett chuckles)
He didn't do all this stuff
that we asked him to do.
So, why don't we just let
the second one just be
a little bit more free.
- @Takingcareofmomma tweeted
back at us as an oldest child,
"That stereotype of the first
born being more cautious
"and law abiding, totally
true in my experience.
"I would even go so far as to
say that I did a terrible job
"of breaking in my parents
before my sister got old enough
"to break the rules."
Yeah, like I said, we had lots of rules
and parameters
for Lily.
And I think that, you
know, grow up in that world
and you're like, okay, this is...
You know, she responded to it.
So, she became the reliable
rule-follower that then,
kind of, as Lincoln and
Lando entered the scene,
she was...
Sometimes we'd treat
her like a third adult.
A lot of first, oldest children
responded and said that
they're the third parent,
the babysitter all the time.
Being given substantial responsibility
to take care of the siblings
and to follow those rules
and to be reliable and counted on
is something that I--
- Well, and
the negative aspect of that--
- It just practically,
it plays out that way.
- But the negative aspect of
that is the bossiness, right?
Like I say,
- Yeah.
- I seem to remember Lily going through
the bossy, older sister phase
- Hm mm.
- which definitely seems
like she's well out of that--
at this point.
- Yeah.
Every everything that we said
to her, then she was like,
"Oh, here's a younger kid in the house,"
"now I can say it to
Lincoln," you know, "I can..."
And can you fault her?
It's like, she's reinforcing the things
that we would have said
to Lincoln too--
- Well, we've had to say.
I can't tell you how many
times we've had to say...
This is not quite as common as it was,
maybe even a year ago,
but for several years
Jesse would have to say, "Locke,
I'm parenting right now."
You know,
(Link chuckles)
because Shepard would be getting
in trouble for something,
she would be saying something,
I would be saying something
and then Locke was like,
"Yeah and," and he's like,
he gets in on it,
right?
(Link chuckles)
So, no, no, no, that's not your role.
Your role is not to parent.
But specifically, we're talking about
with this whole
rule-follower thing, again,
I think this is where it comes down to
your specific personality
and we're going to,
we keep promising it.
We're going to do the
Enneagram episode, right,
But--
- Yes.
- So kids are different (Rhett
chuckles) and recognizing,
like the fact that Locke,
as I've said before,
is more of a challenger.
So, when he sees a rule,
he questions the rule.
It's not just the rule
exists, you follow it.
The rule exists, his
immediate response is,
"Why does that rule exist?"
"Is that rule actually good?"
Does that rule intend what it is,
what it says that it's
intending to prevent, right?
Whereas Shepard is more just like,
I wouldn't say he's a rule
follower, but I wouldn't say
that he's a rule breaker either.
I would say that he's
kinda just his own person
and if the rules suit
him, he'll follow them
and if they don't, he won't.
(Rhett chuckles)
But again, this doesn't seem
to be true with my kids.
I wouldn't say this one's a
rule follower, this one's not.
And--
- Right.
- Maybe it's a little bit, I
mean, how would you perceive me
and my brother growing up?
You might perceive this a little bit?
- I mean,
the consistency of discipline
that you're talking about
does resonate.
I mean, yeah, we would get into trouble
and you would get a punishment
and then they would call
my mom and then tell her
and then if I was involved
to the same degree,
I would just get the same punishment.
But if they didn't have the conversation,
I wouldn't get any punishment at all.
So I knew that you were getting this.
There were always
repercussions for you.
So.
And yeah, so we would
break the rules together,
but I would, you know, we'd
have to read some momentum
and you would have to
overcome a lot--
- But versus me
and my brother--
- But you weren't rebellious.
If you're like,
"Oh Cole is,"
- I think you're the same.
I mean, I think his personality is
probably more of a rule follower,
but I think because of the
discipline in your home,
your actions were similar.
- Yeah, I think we're kinda
the same in this regard.
I think that compared to--
- It's more about them,
the parents--
than it is about--
- Yeah, I would say
compared with--
- your personalities.
- the general population as kids,
both of us were,
what you could call a rule-follower.
Now, we may have been mischievous, right.
- Yeah.
- Those do some prank calls,
or whatever.
Let's listen to, in my
brother's case, it's like,
I'm gonna get
the most explicit gangster
rap cassettes available
and then let my brother and
his best friend listen to 'em.
- Yeah.
But still, am I going to do the things
that the adults in my life
expect, at least externally?
Yes.
Am I gonna be known as a rebel kid?
No.
And that was the same for both of us.
So this trope didn't really hold true.
- Let's move on to the middle
child before we forget.
- Okay.
- I was tempted
to skip middle children entirely
and then at the very end realize it,
as a joke and then just end the episode,
but let's not do that.
Let's talk about middle children.
But first let's sell that T-shirt.
- Yeah.
This is the official
Cotton Candy Randy Savage.
- Ooh yeah, Daddies.
- I don't think that
we can say that it is.
It is not Randy Savage.
- No, it's--
- It's Cotton Candy, Randy,
but it's definitely inspired by the spirit
of Randy Savage,
- Yes.
- which is out there somewhere.
- And which inspires us constantly.
Go to mythical.com to get that
and all of your apparel needs met.
They also have an Amazon
store with different stuff,
amazon.com/mythical.
- Mythical.
All right, so
let's move to youngest child.
(Rhett and Link chuckle)
You get it?
See, I still did it.
All right, middle child.
Cyrus Cole responded, "I'm
number six of nine kids."
That still happens?
Parents still have like
nine kids these days?
- It could be a farm.
- It must be a farm.
- But, no, but now there's
with factory farming,
families don't.
So this is not a farm.
- What is it?
- I dunno.
Parents want audience.
(Rhett laughs)
I mean, when Chrissy and I
first got married and like,
we were friends with families
that had a lot of kids
and we just thought that was.
We'd go visit them,
Chrissy would keep
babysit the kids sometimes
and it would just seem so exciting.
I mean, we thought we were
gonna have like six kids.
That was crazy.
That's crazy talk.
- Well, you wised up.
It only took three--
- Yeah.
- for you to wise up.
- It really, I mean--
- It took two for me.
- Well, after the 2nd one we
had quite a negotiation before
making a 3rd happen.
Because I got to name
him Lando, he exists.
I had to reiterate
(Rhett chuckles)
that story to him the other day.
I don't know why he didn't know that.
I was like, you know--
- "You wouldn't be here
"if your name wasn't Lando.
"Never complain about it."
- "Your mom agreed to
"letting me name the third
child if it was a boy
"and then we went for it."
When she said, "Okay, I will
agree to Lando as a name."
He likes his name though.
Cyrus says, "I'm number six of nine kids.
"Being in the middle left
the impression on me,
"of being easily forgotten
"a lot."
- I think that might just be
because you're one of nine children.
I mean, of course they're
gonna forget--
- This is a trope though.
"Left at stores, church,
et cetera and my favorite,
"not getting picked up from
soccer practice multiple times."
"No cell phone.
"It was quite traumatizing as
a kid and took years to heal."
Dang, Cyrus, thanks for sharing.
I'm sorry that you were traumatized
by being left alone at soccer
practice multiple times.
Yeah, you got the...
But in general, this is the thing.
Middle child just gets lost in the mix.
Not necessarily literally--
- Literally.
- Lincoln, the middle child in our home is
you know, he's quiet.
He's not gonna be the
first to come into a room
and just take over the conversation.
Whereas both Lily and Lando
will do that, you know.
I'm here and I'm assuming
nothing was happening
until I showed up.
Or...
(Link chuckles)
But Lincoln, you realize
he's been there on the couch
for a while.
He kinda slips in
(Rhett chuckles)
and slips out.
Especially over this past year,
there's a lot of slipping into his room
and into his world of video games
and connecting with his friends--
- Right.
- via his headset and screen.
But I've noticed that he
does this thing where...
Well, I'm actually
getting to the next one,
so, I'll wait on that.
But I'm trying to.
Have we left him anywhere?
Not physically.
- I mean, I think that,
again, I can't speak to this
because this doesn't exist in my family,
either the one I came from,
or the one that I currently have.
But I am interested in
if you think that this
Theresa's comment, @yellowsun11,
"I'm number four of five kids
"and I'm definitely a people pleaser
"and try to keep the peace."
"My default is to suppress
my feelings and desires
"as unimportant and instead
defer to my siblings'
"and others' wishes."
"Especially noticeable and annoying
"when trying to decide what's for dinner."
- Well with Lincoln, the one exception is,
what's for dinner.
- Strong opinion about that.
- That is one thing
that he's gonna be the first to suggest,
"Hey, what are we gonna have for dinner?"
"I got an idea."
"We need to get hot
chicken from this place."
"We need to get this type of
chicken from this place," or,
"Hot chicken from this other
place," it's like, he's--
- Hmm.
- Obsessed with that.
- But do you feel like--
- But other than food--
- He's ever been a peacekeeper
between Lily and Lando?
- He is...
He doesn't settle arguments
between the two of them,
but what he does is, he
doesn't ruffle feathers.
He knows how to work with within
me and Christie's demands.
Like if we're like, Clean
your room, or, "Hey."
His job is to take out the trash
and to move the trash cans back
and if I tell him to do it,
he's learned.
Whenever I have a plan, or
even if it's something like,
"Hey you know what, this afternoon,
"I think we're gonna play
a board game as a family,"
he's learned that the best
thing to do is just to say yes.
If I have one of these type of ideas,
even though it may not be what
he wants to do, he knows that
I'm so excited about it
and that the right answer.
He knows what the right
answer is and he will say it,
but then behind the scenes
then practically, he'll do,
he can kind of finesse it
to get some extra screen time out of it.
Or, I'm like, "Hey we're gonna play."
He's in there on his screen,
I go in there and I'm like,
"Hey, we're gonna play a
board game in an hour."
And he's like, "Okay."
I'm like...
It's just so refreshing 'cause
the other two they're like
there's always a negotiation,
well, I got this plan,
or I'm this and I'm that.
I'm sure he has things that
he would rather be doing
and wants to do but he
knows the right answer,
it makes it a lot easier
to then move forward.
And then by the way, an hour from now,
they're probably gonna be
wrapped up in something else
and it'll end up being
two hours, three hours
and we may not play at all.
And I'll just be in here,
"You can come get me
"if you wanna do it."
But he has this zoomed-out perspective
that like...
The conflict and the drama is
just not for him, you know?
So, that's, sometimes what will
be having a dramatic moment
as a family and you look
up and he'll be gone.
It's just like, it's just not--
worth it.
- And that could just be,
that could just be his disposition.
- It could be.
- I mean
both of my kids again--
- But it is a trope
kinda thing.
- If I open the door and say,
and I could be like, "We're going to have
"a circus at our house and everything
"that you've ever wanted
will be available to you."
They'll be like, "Well, I've got plans."
Like,
all you gotta do is have a suggestion
as to something that you wanna do
and my kids
- Right.
- will respond with why
they don't wanna do it.
It's almost like, again,--
- I again--
- it's a knee-jerk response.
- Two outta three, that's the
experienced in my home too.
- So, yeah, it could be.
But you don't see him settling arguments
between Lilly and Lando?
- No, I see--
- Being the negotiator?
- No, what see him doing
is just like smiling
and kinda laughing at it.
Like shaking his head.
- Right.
He's always like, "I'm, not in this fray."
It's not...
You know, he prides himself
on living low-stress life,
staying on the fringe of things,
you know?
- Well, I mean,
I would say--
- Go with the flow.
- What I would have said, not
just about middle children,
but definitely, like in
Cyrus's case with being
six of nine kids, I have
to believe, and again,
and we're gonna jump
around a little bit here
because I'm gonna get your
responses and only child to this
because my...
The one thing that makes
sense to me, and again,
I don't know what the
science says about this,
it just seems logical, is
that the larger the family,
the more you had to
learn to be deferential
and accommodating to people in your space.
It might be you had, just
something as simple as,
if you shared a room
with someone, growing up,
you are going to be...
The way that you defer to people
and the way that you
see your personal space
and the way that you see your
items and getting your way,
is going to be different than somebody
who was by themselves.
And I've always thought that that's why
you are really particular
about a lot of things.
And when things--
- Oh, yeah.
When people try to take
in a different direction,
it's a big adjustment
because you didn't have
to accommodate anybody.
And I had to do that a little
bit with having one brother,
but somebody like Cyrus,
who's from a family of nine,
you could talk that guy
into anything, right?
- Probably.
- I mean, (Rhett
chuckles) in other words--
- We're gonna test it, Cyrus.
- Flexibility.
I would think that the
size of your family,
not in every case, has
to have some correlation
to your personal flexibility.
- Yeah, asserting your
own preferences, or not,
or deferring.
Consideration.
- And expect.
And sort of having an expectation.
Like if your preferences always won,
then you're going to have a bigger problem
with your preferences
not winning, as an adult.
Right or wrong?
- Yeah, I think so 'cause it's,
yeah, it's a shock to
the system when you...
Yeah, absolutely.
- Right.
- I don't know if there was...
When I left home and went off to college
and we became roommates that
would have been the first test
of like, oh, I'm living in
the same room with somebody.
I don't recall us having arguments
about that at that point.
- I feel like the reason
that it's worked mostly well,
it might, I mean, there may be like things
that are mildly annoying to me,
but I feel like the reason
that most of that has.
In fact, we were talking to
Mike McCarthy the other day
and we were talking about the fact
that we were college
roommates and he was like,
"Oh, and you're still friends?"
That's the amazing thing is that
you lived together during college.
That's a huge test of friendship.
- Yeah.
- I think a big part of it is
most of the things that
you are particular about
in a living space,
I kinda just don't care.
Like, how cold is it in here?
I don't know.
I don't really care.
Make it the temperature that
you want, you what I'm saying.
I don't have an equally strong opinion
about a lot of those things.
So, I would just say, "Where
should this poster be?
"Where should this couch be?"
- You had assertive parents
and you had an older brother
and I had,
I had myself.
- Right and so I just tend
to be like, all right,
Link's gonna have an opinion about
where this couch is and et cetera
and I don't have an opinion about it
and so why didn't he just
make the decision about this.
- Yeah, @hannahbatch
said, "I'm an only child
"and my fiance is a middle
child of four and it's perfect.
"I'm used to getting my way
"and he's used to letting other
people do what they want."
So in our dynamic, it does work.
I mean, if you were a firstborn,
that would be an interesting test.
- If we were both
only children--
- Oh, gosh.
If we were both
only children--
- we wouldn't be sitting
at this table--
- I don't think that.
- I don't think there'll be.
There will be no test at all.
- And I tend to be really.
I tend to be a very deferential person
when it comes to a whole slew of like,
you know, what things look like,
what things feel like,
living situation, bathroom.
I tend to be very deferential
about all that stuff.
I'm....
But there are things that
I care a whole lot about
but it tends to be a pretty
narrow spectrum of things
that I care a whole lot about
and I kinda put all my
energy into those things.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't even know exactly
what those things are,
but I think that's one of the reasons
that this has not been a lasting
source of conflict for us.
- Yeah.
We're in a fortunate birth
order situation here.
Let's go to youngest children.
This is you.
So, we're onto you.
@RachelBlack said, "I'm the
youngest out of my sister and I
"and I get away with a lot more,
"but also don't have the
high expectations put on me
"which can be both good and bad."
- I mean, we kind of talked
about this a little bit.
For me this was not the case
because my parents were super consistent.
It is kind of the case with our kids,
but I think it's a combination of factors,
but without a doubt.
Like what Shepard is allowed to watch,
what Shepherd is allowed to say--
- Yeah.
- What he's allowed to do,
is significantly more lenient than...
I mean, you know, again,
we come from a conservative
evangelical background.
Early on, when Locke was really little,
and he wanted to play with Pokemon cards,
Jesse had questions about that
because of the evolution
aspect of Pokemon cards.
I mean that's how ingrained that idea was.
Is like, "I don't know about that
"because I know that those things evolve."
- Right.
(Rhett laughs)
Just to give you a little
slice of where we come from.
- That one's more extreme
than the Harry Potter example,
which was also true.
It's like, Harry Potter really took off
before we were having
kids, but we were too old
to be into it ourselves.
But eventually Lily got
into it, but it wasn't.
I mean, Lando is reading Harry Potter now
and has been for a year
or so, but when Lily was,
you know, nine, 10, 11 years old,
there was no Harry Potter in our house.
- Right.
Because of the witchcraft stuff?
- And because I wasn't into
it and it was a residual
of that witchcraft stuff
that was just like,
practically speaking,
we're not gonna get you--
- But now--
- into that stuff--
- if I went
into Shepard's room and he was reading
"The Adventures of Satan and his Demons,"
I'd be like, "Are you into that?"
(Rhett guffaws)
- Right.
- I'm just saying I've completely,
again, I'm not scared
of any of that stuff.
I don't believe that it's a reality, so.
In other words, like--
- And we're not gonna push
our kids towards something
by trying to, by setting
up the goals for them
to kick against.
- Yeah.
- I think that's another part
of our philosophy that has shifted.
Is, you know, don't let
fear-drive set up walls.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's more
like let's have open
conversations about things
and if there are legitimate
dangers associated with things,
then let's really get into
the details and discuss it.
So, it's not about just a blind rule,
or all of a sudden there's a wall here
and it's like, no questions asked.
- Well, yeah and to clarify,
I'm using the example
of "The Adventures of
Satan and his Demons"
as a purposely inflammatory
thing that I know
is going to upset some people,
because, you know, I like to do that,
but it's kind of like
- He does not have that book?
- He does not have that book.
It was just a funny example.
But even if you think about,
let's just talk about the
Lil Nas X-thing for a second
and the Satanic panic that's
happening around that.
I do think that, you know, rewind 10 years
and if my kid.
And neither one of my kids
would consider themselves
much of a Lil Nas X fan,
but they're both aware
of the Montero video and the
controversy that it's causing.
There was a time where
I would have been afraid
to just let them watch that
and for us to have a
conversation about it.
Now, I understand that the
whole point of the video
is to cause the panic
and cause that reaction
for branding purposes.
That's what Lil Nas X was
doing from the very beginning
and a bunch of people took the bait
and got very upset about it.
I mean, it was hook, line and sinker,
they just took the bait and
got upset about the video
and the shoes that had
blood in them, right.
A lot of people.
And I think that now it's just like,
hey, can't we step back and just.
It isn't like, "Oh,
kids you can do and say
"whatever you want to."
It's not that there are no rules.
It's that the things that are important
and the things that are
actually going to be
potentially harmful and dangerous to them,
let's have real meaningful
conversations about them.
And let's kind of say
that, hey all these things
that we thought might be
dangerous and harmful,
actually aren't and we can
still have a conversation
about why some people see it that way, so.
- So with our youngest kids,
there's a lot more leniency
in our parenting because,
because we're
(Link chuckles)
evolving.
Our perspectives are evolving
and there's so much that you
wanna protect your kids from
in every single day.
There's so much more out there
that they can be exposed to,
that could be damaging.
So you've gotta be even more strategic
in choosing the right battles,
because if you battle everything,
there's a sense that it just won't work.
- And I think that there--
- Nothing will stick.
- As a very, very broad generalization,
there are two types of kids, right?
There are the kids who are going to do
the subversive transgressive things
and there are kids who
are not going to do them.
And whether and if you are the kind of kid
who is sort of wired to do
the transgressive things
and you grow up in a really
conservative atmosphere,
you are going to break bad
and you're going to break bad
in a real big way a lot of times.
But if you're a rule-follower
when you grow up in that,
you might just get out okay
and just be a rule-follower
for the rest of your life.
- Or you might get fixated on it.
Like, I mean, with Lando,
he's at a stage right now
and we're figuring it out in what it means
and kinda tracing it back
and figuring out what our path forward is.
But he gets worked up about
anything that feels like
it's a violation of a rule.
Not like a societal rule,
whether it's a curse word,
or even anything that's
offensive, or embarrassing,
like a fart--
- And again,
that's not something
- You know, he's
- that came from you?
- No, he's very sensitive.
So for him, it's like, we're
trying to help him understand
a grid through which to interpret
what is actually dangerous
what does it mean for
something to be offensive,
you know, or not.
So that there's not
unnecessarily tall walls built up
around him that keeps him
from truly fully experiencing
his life.
(Link chuckles)
- Right.
So, another way
to say it is--
- So, it's like
tearing down walls for him.
- We're both,
I would say, to similar degrees,
lenient on our youngest
kids, but they operate
with different levels of personal leniency
because they are different kids.
- Oh yeah.
- Again, I just think it
so much has to do with
just the disposition of the kid.
It's...
I don't know, the more I parent
the more powerless I feel as a parent.
(both laugh)
I'm just being honest with you.
That's my experience.
Now, this aspect of being a younger child
really intrigues me.
From Paridhi,
@mythicanoi, "I'm two years
younger than my sister."
"It's a bittersweet relationship."
"One thing I hate about it
is all the competition."
"All my grades are compared to hers."
"All my talents are
compared to that of hers."
"Living that way for 18 years,
"I have learned to calculate my self-worth
"from other people's achievements."
"It's not about what I
like, or what I can do,
"it's more about, am I
better than the other person
"because that is the only way
my parents will accept me."
- Hmm.
- Wow, okay, so we've talked a lot
about my competitive nature.
We had one very infamous podcast
where I tried to convince you
that you were also competitive.
(Link chuckles)
- And I won that argument.
- Yeah.
- So--
- That was a joke.
- I am, and I think
another way to say it is,
I definitely come from a
performance-based household, right?
Now, I am incredibly
thankful and grateful for
the way my parents raised me and I think
I have so much to be thankful for.
I do think that they had high
expectations for performance.
It was like, when you
brought home the good grades
or you excelled in a sport,
you received praise for
those kinds of things.
So I think that the way that
my personality interacted
with that is, I was like, "Oh,
I see how this game works."
And I turned a lot of things into a game
and it's turned me into a
very performance-based person.
I'm an Enneagram Three and so I kinda
enter into every single arena of life
thinking about how I can win, right?
How I can come out on
top of the situation.
Not necessarily at the
expense of other people,
but just like, I want
to be good at this thing
that I am now engaging with.
I've never thought about it
being anything to do with birth order,
or in comparison to my brother until now.
(Rhett chuckles)
Until this observation--
- So,
do you recall, I mean comparing yourself?
He was older.
I don't know if basketball
is a good example.
I know that you guys both were
laser focused on basketball.
He was on the high school team.
You were on the JV team as a freshman,
so you were never on the same squad.
- One game.
- One game?
- State playoffs, my freshman year,
they pulled me up to varsity
and we were on the court
in the first round of the state playoffs
for like a few plays.
- And did you--
- Coach, just did it.
I think he just did it
so it could be like,
the McLaughlin boys are on
the floor at the same time.
- You would you pass it
(indiscernible)
to each other?
I mean, I was a freshmen.
I was like, I'd been on JV.
I'd been on JV, not starting,
by the way, as a freshmen.
- Oh, so you just, your pants?
- Because Coach Mace,
in his great wisdom played
Jason Batman before me.
- Oh, you're bitter.
(Rhett guffaws)
- I am a little bit bitter about that,
but Coach Gage was
like, "I don't know what
"Coach Mace doing, but
I know that you're good
"and we're gonna bring you up to varsity
"in your sophomore year," which he did,
but he also brought me up
for the state playoffs.
So, yeah, there was a--
- You guys will be out in your front yard,
on your basketball court,
both doing drills.
- There was a whole lot
of competitiveness between the two of us
with whatever we were doing.
- Like playing one-on-one?
- Playing, one-on-one, playing horse.
Some of the most epic, long,
extended games of horse
in the summertime.
One-on-one games that would
often end with me crying
and running inside because
I was the younger one
and I was losing most almost all the time
maybe till...
In high school, every once in a while
I might be able to win just
'cause I was getting so tall.
- Uh, huh, how tall is Cole?
- 6'2"?
- Okay.
- 6.
- Okay, yeah.
He might have me by a couple inches.
- I think that...
Here's the thing, I
think that he also might.
I don't know if he knows
what Enneagram he is,
but he's got a lot of, 3 in him.
And so,
I think that he's also an
achiever and a performer.
And so I don't think,
again, I don't think it was,
hey, I'm a performer because
I was a younger sibling.
I think that maybe both of us are that way
because there was, first of
all, kind of pre-wired to that
and then growing up in a family
that kinda reinforced that.
So, we both kinda are task
and goal-oriented people.
But there was a lot of comparison,
but I don't remember,
I don't remember--
- Like you didn't--
- My parents saying things
like, "Well, your brother
"did this so you need to do that."
I don't remember,
I don't remember that.
You guys had a decent relationship.
I mean, from my perspective,
coming over for sleepovers,
I would interact with Cole too.
We would listening to music.
Yes, he would give me the LL Cool J tape
and you would play the Young MC tape
and you would both try to tell me who,
try to argue which was the coolest
and which made me feel awesome.
I was like the swing vote here.
But he wasn't--
- Was cooler?
Young MC?
- I think you had the Young MC tape, yeah.
And he had a...
Kool Moe Dee is cooler.
- But you said LL Cool J.
- And Kool Moe, he had both of those.
You know, he had--
- Young MC is not cool.
He was cool for a
moment, but no longevity.
- Yeah.
Your brother was right at the time.
But my point is when I would
come over to a sleepover,
there will be interactions,
I would experience...
You know, I would see you two interact.
It's not like he wouldn't
have anything to do with me,
or you, because we were so much younger.
You guys had an active relationship.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
there was a friendship
component to it, right?
You didn't hate each other.
(Link chuckles)
- We got into a lot of fights.
I would say that...
I dunno.
I don't think we were as
emotionally available to each other
and reliant on each other, as I would say
even Locke and Shepard are.
And Locke and Shepard have a
much larger age difference,
which can both exacerbate and help that
sort of reliance on one another.
I think in their case it has
enhanced that emotional connection.
But I think that, it wasn't
until we got to be adults,
that we would maybe have
a conversation that was--
- Heavy.
- Deeper and kinda went
below the surface of like,
are we talking.
As kids, it was, let's
have a conversation about
what we're doing and how
we're doing it better,
how we could do it better.
But we're not gonna have a
conversation about how we feel,
(Rhett chuckles)
you know?
But that was kinda also a
family thing for us too, right.
We didn't talk a whole lot
about feelings in my family.
It wasn't that feelings
were bad, it was just that,
it wasn't something that...
Talking about feelings was not valued.
- But you didn't.
My perception is you
didn't have any buried
feelings of animosity
towards your brother.
- No.
- I mean,
the fights that you would have as in...
He would pick on you about
having a crush on somebody
and then you would get really angry.
And I remember him
running back into his room
and you had a stick of
deodorant in your hand
and you threw it at his door
- Yeah.
- That he just slammed in your face.
And I think it made a hole in the door.
- I think it may have dented it.
Yeah, and I think--
- And I was there.
- the thing about that is that--
- I was like, I'm glad I'm an only child.
- He would see--
- I don't wanna get it
with deodorant.
- He would see that he
could get you to join in
and that would make me very mad.
If he recruited my friends
- Embarrassing.
to be a part of this thing.
Like that's harder to with
than just him doing it.
But he would also do this
thing where he would...
No one really talked about this but...
I've seen this with Locke and Shepard.
Now this is an older, younger
thing I've seen quite a bit.
He would talk about how it was gonna be
so difficult for me when I
got to, fill-the-blank grade.
He'd be like, "When you get to 4th grade,
(Link guffaws)
"it's gonna rock your world."
And then I would get to 4th
grade and it would be just
as fun as 1st grade.
I always loved school and never thought
that it was difficult, right.
And--
- So, it never worked?
He never scared you?
- Every time I would get to
the grade, it would be fine.
And it became a...
(Link chuckles)
It became this funny,
like, recurring joke in my family.
It was, "Well Rhett's in 7th grade now and
"he says it's okay," you know?
So, Cole definitely would
warn me about things.
That would happen quite a bit.
- I'm super-jealous of not
having an older brother.
Like when it comes to music is one thing.
That's why I brought that up, is that,
or whatever the case.
Whether it's like.
My development was stunted, I believe.
When you have an older brother,
like you're talking about.
You're observing Cole with his girlfriend
and figuring out, kinda between the lines
what they're up to, you know?
It might be, you know, you're
gaining confidence that,
"I know this guy, I live with this guy.
"This guy is ridiculous."
"If he can have a girlfriend,
I can have a girlfriend."
You know, it was like,
I had so little confidence
to even have a girlfriend
and I felt like I missed out on that.
When it came to music,
it was just exposure to
cool things that were above my head.
Or movies, you know?
- Yeah, most of the kids--
- Everything--
- who end up introducing you to
the things that are for older kids,
usually have an older brother.
- Right.
Like Lando watches...
He's got a lot of stipulations
about what he'll allow himself to enjoy.
(Rhett chuckles)
Again, it's self-imposed,
but for us, it's like,
again we wanna watch things that we enjoy
and he's just along for the ride.
Whereas with the younger kids,
when the first kids were younger,
it was more just catering to
things that were age-specific.
But by the time you get
to three, it's just like,
hey, you're gonna be
stretched a little bit
because there's other people pulling
the median age of this whole group up
so gotta adapt.
- That not a birth order thing,
that's a personality thing
because most, well in my
experience personally,
in my experience with my
family and what I would say
is my anecdotal evidence,
most younger kids are excited
about getting to do the things
that their older siblings
were not allowed to do.
Like the idea of getting
away with something,
watching something that
you're not supposed to watch.
Most kids are kinda like,
they don't impose their own
standards like Lando does.
And so, I just think, again,
that's not of birth order,
family dynamic thing.
I just think this is how these
particular kids are wired.
- I wanted to bring up another dynamic.
I love when we put out these prompts
and then we get back something
that wasn't on our radar.
And I'm not talking about if you're a twin
because we've made an
executive decision that
we're not talking about twins.
They creep me out.
- Yeah.
- And I don't wanna have nothing
to do with 'em.
- Speaking of the devil.
- So they are--
- Twins are the result
of the devil's activity.
(Link chuckles)
- You guys are out.
- Triplets, whoa, don't get me
started on that.
- No.
Don't even say the word quadruplets.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh!
But I thought this is great.
I'll bundle these three together.
If you have a sibling with special needs.
Ashleigh tweeted, "I'm the youngest
"with just an older brother."
"My brother has autism."
"It's weird being the youngest by age,
"but being treated like the
oldest for most things."
"I'm more of a parent
than a sister to him."
"Love my brother to death though
"and wouldn't change a thing."
Sophia responded said,
"Being the younger sibling
"of an autistic child
has been tough at times,
"but it has also given me
compassion and patience
"at the times I needed it the most."
And then Caroline responded,
"Also younger sibling."
"I'm the youngest, but one of
my older brothers is disabled
"and has always needed
round the clock care.
"I'm now a special school
teacher and have a passion
"for helping disabled
students find purpose."
I love the fact that
we got these responses
to expand this conversation.
It's interesting that all three
of them are younger siblings
who have an older, special need sibling.
Obviously that's not always the case,
but I think it's a little
more unexpected that,
okay, as a younger sibling,
you're not getting away with more,
you're having this older
sibling experience and it's...
You know, being a part of
a family dynamic like this,
you learn things that a lot of us
never have, I will say,
the privilege of learning,
expand who you are.
I love when they're all saying,
"I wouldn't change it for the world."
"I've grown so much as a person."
"I've accessed a level of
compassion and patience
- Yeah.
- "that develops me."
I mean, it's well, and
that's extremely difficult,
but very cool.
- I don't have any
personal experience with this,
but everyone that I know,
who has a family member
with special needs,
has
this increased, sort of,
appreciation for life.
And I don't mean like, oh, I'm so glad
that I'm not in this situation, but no,
like being in the
relationship with a person
who has special needs has given
them a perspective on life
that is deeper.
And it's not, you know.
You got Caroline saying that
she is helping disabled
students find purpose.
I also think that disabled
people help us find purpose.
- Hm.
- You know what I'm saying?
I think that that is a really
common theme that you see
in people who have
members in their families
who have special needs is
that they have not been.
Now, first of all, okay,
yes, in lots of cases,
maybe there is a burden
aspect to it in that
this is a lot of work,
this is a lot of attention.
There's a lot of sacrifices
that are made by parents
and by siblings,
of course, that's an aspect.
- Sure.
- I can only.
I can't imagine because I
don't have that experience.
But at the same time I think
that there's a huge blessing
that comes with that and
I think you're seeing that
in these in these mythical
beasts who shared.
- As we shift to the only child responses,
I'm just very, I'm just struck with
how much you are shaped by
the environment you grew up in
in terms of like, again, it's
not just about birth order,
but it's about additional
personalities in your home.
And the deeply intimate level
of exposure you have to people
who are either adults or
developing kids at different ages.
It's just, I mean, it
has to have an impact on
how you develop,
at least in the short-term
when you're in that situation,
in comparison to being an only child.
Being in people's mess, you know,
(Link chuckles)
and understanding.
You just really get to know people
(Link chuckles)
when you're related to
them and live with them
and living on top of each other.
And yeah, so I do feel like I missed out.
Bri Shear tweeted, "Growing
up being an only child
"was awful."
Wow.
"I was so lonely.
"I always wanted a sibling and
constantly annoyed my parents
"to give me one."
(Link laughing)
So, "Give me a sibling."
Well, you know, there's
a process involved,
- Yeah, or a stork.
- Bri.
I have a--
- Did you want this?
- I have a lot of...
I don't recall ever asking for a sibling.
I mean, you know, my mom...
Yeah, 'cause I had the half-sister
and then there was the
divorce and it was just like,
well, it's like, okay mom is single.
It's just the two of us.
It just wasn't an environment to
hope for a sibling.
It didn't seem like that was something
that was gonna happen.
And there's also some--
- Maybe there are
some kids that would have been like,
"Aww, I hope she gets married
and then I'll have like...
"There'll be a baby."
Did you ever think?
- I don't think so.
Yeah, I don't think so.
- Did you ever hang out
with babies
and think, "Oh I would like
one of these in my house?"
- She had a...
Her friend, Donna, I
remember had this cute
little toddler daughter.
And I remember being infatuated with her
in a younger sister kind of
way, like holding the baby,
or playing with the toddler.
I mean, I had a few baby dolls myself.
And I don't know if that was some sort.
I think there was a.
It was more of a,
it's so, you know, these
babies are so cute,
but maybe there was a loneliness thing.
I definitely remember being in my room,
even when I had the step-sister.
That age difference was such that
we really didn't have a relationship.
I would be in my room a
lot, listening to the radio,
or playing with my G.I. Joes, you know,
I've told this story.
I didn't listen to the radio,
or music for the longest time
because my stepsister liked music.
- Yeah.
- I just wanted to assert--
- You gotta differentiate yourself--
- myself.
But yeah and I was certainly
lonely and I had this...
Sav tweeted at us.
S-A-V, siccvanna,
"As an only child from Harnett
County with a single mom,"
What!
- What!
- Just like me.
"I felt like I was
socially behind my peers."
"It wasn't until college
that I found and developed
"a personality and opinions
that were wholly my own."
"I struggle with boundaries of oversharing
"and self isolation."
"I often resent not having
a sibling to confide in
"who could understand exactly
where I'm coming from,
"without the judgment
that a parent might have."
"Even when I know my parents
want the best for me,
"it's still a lot of
pressure and responsibility
"to be a, 'Good daughter.'"
So, I mean, I relate to
being socially stunted.
I was...
You had a voracious
appetite to spend the night
at other kids' homes (Link
chuckles) of any age.
(Link chuckles)
- Yeah.
- And that's so strange to me.
- Insatiable.
- I mean, as close as we became,
I know I was very anxious
to go spend the night at your
house or, other kids' homes
and I rarely did it.
I just didn't.
And then whenever I would go
over and we would interact
with the other kids in the neighborhood,
it was a high-anxiety situation
for me, looking back on it.
I just wasn't.
I wasn't used to being around
a bunch of boisterous, assertive kids.
I definitely remember in preschool,
being afraid of all the other boys
and I would hang out with the girls
because at least they were chilled out.
- But you also went to preschool,
kinda daycare situation
earlier than I did.
- I did, yeah.
I did preschool out here
actually, in Thousand Oaks
was the first.
But yeah, it's funny because I actually
am more on the introverted
side as an adult.
I'm fine with large groups of
people and I can adapt to it
and I don't have a lot
of anxiety, it's just,
it's not my preference.
My preference is to be alone, right.
But it's weird that as a kid,
my preference was very much like...
It's almost like I got
it all out of the way.
It was like--
- Oh, and you know,
and we changed over time
in that way too.
- Yeah, and so--
- It's not locked in, that's for sure.
- 'Cause I actually consider you, I mean,
I don't know.
You're kinda borderline
introvert, extrovert, I think.
- I'm trying to figure
out how much this pandemic
has influenced that about me
because I'm noticing that I
really have to make up my mind
to get out of my house and my comfort zone
and my very small plans.
So, I'm in a transition
period of getting back out
into the world, as a lot of us are.
Back in the day, as a kid,
I caught up, but I had a
lot of catching up to do
by high school.
- And we've talked about this before,
but I never perceived any of this.
I did not have any perception
that you were uncomfortable.
I mean, okay, yeah, we
went to Camp Caraway
and you didn't take a dump
the entire week,
(Link chuckles)
but I was just like,
okay, I mean, it happens.
(Link chuckles)
- Sometimes doesn't happen,
(both laugh)
right?
But I don't remember thinking, I mean,
maybe my mom was like, "You
know, Link is having a,"
she never told me, at
least I don't remember,
"Link is really nervous about this week
"and you need to help him."
- Right.
- I didn't have any idea
that you were not having a
great time that I was having.
Every single thing that we
were doing, I was just like,
"Everything about this is awesome."
I tend to think that about
everything that I'm experiencing.
I tend to think that I inflate it
and make it even better
than it actually is
before and after and during.
I don't know where that comes from,
but I never had any indication that
you weren't just having as
great of a time as I was having.
- Yeah, for me, I mean, if I
try to get specific to like,
if you have an older sibling
who's gonna hold you down
and drip spit from their mouth
and dangle it onto your face--
- Never hit my face
- Again, right.
- Had a lot of control.
- It never hit your face, so
you're learning, it's like,
this guys all bark, no bite,
but for some--
- We never punched each other
in the face.
- You never punched
each other in the face?
- We did the old Charley horse.
That was our go-to.
- But for me, you know, I
had to learn this out in the,
with acquaintances.
It's like, this person is boisterous.
I don't know what they're up against.
Does this kid have a knife?
None of the kids had knives, but it...
And I don't recall fixating on knives,
but I'm just using an example
(Link chuckles) of like,
you know, I had to assess
these things and come to these
experience, how people
put on certain ways.
And that doesn't necessarily
mean that they can back it up,
or that that's the complete
picture of who they are.
The more people you live
with and grow up with,
the more you realize
we're all full of shit
and we're all, you know,
we're all putting on our masks
and protecting ourselves.
'Cause you can see through
that in your own home.
I just have one person in my
home for most of my growing up.
So, I just had that data point.
- But that might
- But the science says
that you catch up and you're okay.
- I just don't know how much, I mean,
I think that the whole, I
definitely think that the whole
feeling like you're behind and like,
"Oh, I'm hearing this for the first time,
"because I didn't have a
older brother older sister
"to tell me," that completely makes sense.
But the anxiety, or, "I
don't trust this person,"
I tend to think that it's
just personality
- Personality.
- Sure, sure.
It has a lot to do with that.
I mean, I wonder if my kids asked me
"How many kids I should have?"
I mean, you know, we're in
such a different world now,
but I think my inclination,
based on my experience
is to not...
And I'll even make a joke
with people, sometimes.
It goes something like this,
"Congratulations on the new baby."
"Go ahead and have another
one 'cause you don't wanna...
"Only child, you don't
wanna do that to your kids."
And it's not really joking.
- And then they're like,
"Well, that's what we
were planning on doing."
"We're in Los Angeles and
we just want one child."
- I know.
I try not to tell people
how many kids to have
unless they ask me and no one ever ask me,
so I end up--
- So you just tell 'em anyway.
If I'm pressed to give advice, it would be
"Don't just have one kid."
It's better, it's better on everybody
to have a second one except
for the parents, I think.
- So you either don't have children,
or if you're gonna have
children, have two kids?
- Yeah.
- Or three?
- I'm happy that we have three.
I can't imagine having four.
I mean, like,
he really slipped under
the wire there, you know.
Barely got through and I'm glad he did,
but there's never ever a point in my mind
that I wish I had a fourth kid.
- Well, there are--
- Never--
- There are times--
- Chrissy sometimes seems like
she wants a baby again and
I'm like, (Link screams)
I like have this
reaction.
- Well, it's funny
- 'cause Jesse,
I would say,
multiple times a year,
maybe she'll be a day late and then,
she'll be like, "What if I'm pregnant?"
She imagines what it would
feel like to be pregnant.
And thus far it is--
- Imagine--
- It's definitely seeming
like she's staring
into an abyss of doom
when she thinks about it.
- Well, you can't help her
with it.
Imagining what it would
be like to be pregnant
is a good exercise
because that is not a...
That's a tough experience.
Having another child, or having a baby
is a thing that somehow
some people still think
is a great idea.
- Well, so there's definitely
nothing about, there's nothing from Jessie
where she's excited about it.
And again, I'm very, very unlikely
to make my wife pregnant at this point
having had a vasectomy.
(Link chuckles)
- Not impossible,
but very unlikely, right?
So for me, it all just
boils down to the fact
that I've always wanted a daughter
and my only daughter is Barbara.
And I treat her like a little girl
and I talk to her about
all that she can achieve
in anything that she wants and, you know,
(Link chuckles)
girl power.
All my girl power sort of
encouragement goes to my dog.
And that's kind of cool in one sense
but it's a little bit sad because
Barbara gonna die at some point.
Before she gets to be the age
where she would go off to
college, she's gonna die.
- Yeah, I'm glad that we experienced
a daughter and sons.
And that dynamic, having a daughter first
and like the whole
bossiness we talked about,
I think that really played
into her personality
and stuff like that as
opposed to having a,
if Lincoln was first and
Lily was in the middle.
Who knows?
Everything will be different, maybe.
So I think it--
- Can I have the last word?-
- It all has an impact,
but then it doesn't have
this lasting, like deterministic impact.
- Well, speaking of twins,
we can close with this.
(Rhett chuckles)
This is where twins are
actually really helpful, right.
Is, and I'm not talking about
like planned twin experiments
but there are some sort of
just circumstantial experience
experiments where twins grow
up in different environments
for they got separated
at birth or whatever.
- Hm mm?
- I don't know the results of those.
So I'm not going to speak up about it.
But that is the only way to
know what you just talked about
which is like, well,
what would Lily be like
if she wasn't the oldest child,
is if she had a twin that
grew up in a different place
or better yet a triplet or a quadruplet.
And they all grew up in different places.
- Hope nobody comes out of the woodwork.
- I mean, the author of the
book, "The Sibling Effect,
"What the Bonds Among Brothers
and Sisters Reveal About Us,"
Jeffrey Kluger, said for plenty
of us, the only ones left
at the end of the dance will
be the ones who brung us.
The brothers and sisters who have been
with us the longest loved us the hardest
and by a wide margin, know us the best.
So if you, if you've got
a sibling that you love
send them some love
today, and if you don't
we'll send you some love right now.
- I do think that that
that's a good point.
It's one thing to have
parents who know you
and, you know, when you're like us,
and you've lived sort of
a weird unexpected life
and being able to be
successful in a medium
where we become these public figures
that more people know us
than we know people, right?
Because of our faces being out there
and almost everyone who has
a perception of who we are
has an incorrect perception of who we are.
People--
- Incomplete--
- Like, or don't like, whatever.
Their perception of us is a projection
that we have chosen to curate
and put on the internet.
Now it's pretty personal.
It's pretty real, but
it is a curation, right?
If you're a fan of us, you
like us, you don't like
who we are and who we would
be if you were to live with us
or if you were to have grown up with us.
Now having parents who
can always ground you
and always bring you back down
to who you really are, is one thing.
It is another thing to have a sibling,
to have someone who is in your generation,
who knows exactly who you are
and sees you for exactly who you are.
And I think that that's something
that my brother can do fairly well
is when I have a conversation with him...
Having a conversation
with him is by default
a grounding experience, right?
He's not trying to ground me.
He's not trying to bring me down--
- Right.
- But you just,
when you've got somebody who knows you
apart from the curated public image,
and this could be good friends, too.
I mean, it's one of
the reasons that people
who are like super-famous
celebrities who have created
sort of cocoon of
people-pleasers around them,
tend to be these narcissistic monsters.
- Hmm.
- It's people who,
regardless of what level of,
society, they have
ascended to, quote unquote,
have people who know exactly who they are
and will tell them
exactly what they think.
That's a healthy thing.
And I think that siblings,
you need a sibling
because of that, I guess you just got me.
- Yeah, you're the closest thing I got.
And we use the marriage analogy more
than the sibling analogy
because when there's no blood,
then if you can end at any moment.
- Will there be blood?
- We're not blood related,
we will never be blood.
- If we punch each other in
the face, there might be.
- Okay, you can deflect it at this point,
(Rhett chuckling)
but I'm saying, yeah,
there is something different
in our relationship
than you have with your
brother, because of that,
the way the bond was determined,
like there's something
to the blood of it all.
- For sure.
- It's immutable.
- Yeah.
- And plus, he's not in your, you know,
you're not working with
them every single day.
And, we're not just friends
where you got this business
that we're, you know, and this brand
and everything that
we're creating together
is an extremely connecting
and complicating factor
in this conversation.
But that's why you have
something with Cole
and those conversations that, yeah,
I guess I don't have anybody in that sense
and you're not it.
- Hmm.
- I just don't have it.
- Maybe you can get like a
brother, a brother for hire.
- I'm okay.
I'm good enough, you know...
- You can't recreate that anyway.
- I would just rather get my
way more often in other senses.
- Okay, well--
(crosstalk)
- Just to play the--
- The only child card.
- So you've got a brother,
I've got the only child card.
Okay, it all evens out.
- Let us know what you think.
Thank you for those of
the hundreds of you,
who who interacted with
us on Twitter and, um...
- You got a wreck?
- We'll keep the conversation going.
In the meantime, I do
have a wreck and effect,
complete left turn,
unrelated to everything
that we're talking about.
Just a book that I'm reading.
It is actually super-relevant right now.
I found myself wanting to read this book,
because one of the
interesting thing that things
that has happened as
we're kind of coming out
of the pandemic and things
are getting back to normal is,
"Oh, what do you know?"
Mass shootings are a thing again--
- Hmm...
- In America, right?
Sadly, tragically.
And there's all this debate
about the Second Amendment.
And I just found myself thinking,
"You know, I don't really..."
"I hear people say things
about the Second Amendment
"and I either didn't pay
attention when we talked
"about this in class, or
I was never taught it."
And so I was like, I'm
going to start maybe reading
about the history of the Second Amendment
and it's its formulation.
So I read this book or I'm like
three quarters of the way through it.
"The Second Amendment, a
Biography," by Michael Waldman
not a brand new book I
think it was written in 2014
won some awards is highly regarded
as a great comprehensive
sort of exploration
of the history of the Second Amendment.
Both, I started realizing
there was so little that I knew
and understood about the
formation of the Constitution
and the Bill of Rights.
I couldn't, I'm just going
to be honest with you,
I couldn't have told you
that the Bill of Rights
was like the first list of
amendments that was added
to the constitution after it was written.
- I think I could have told
you that, but only that.
- Like I knew, I couldn't
have told you that
and I didn't know exactly why it happened
and what it was a reaction to
and what the concerns were at the time.
I was pretty ignorant of this.
So if you're also ignorant of it
or you just happen to be
interested in this kind of thing
I recommend, it's a short
read and it's an easy read.
It's not like super academic or anything.
"The Second Amendment, a
Biography," by Michael Waldman
just a nice introduction to this
which I think then does
influence the way that we think
about this very divisive and inflamed
but very important debate that
we're having in our country
as we're trying to navigate
being the country that leads
in a lot of things, including
by a long shot and by
a large margin, people who
get killed by gun violence.
(relaxing music)
- "The Second Amendment, a
Biography," Michael Waldman.
All right, y'all, #Ear Biscuits.
(upbeat music)
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.
(cheerful music concludes)